that Jason when you were filming with
Jennifer you did not spot her jewelry in
the scene you didn't who here knows what
that is
polymers as a [ __ ] ring obviously yeah
is it really that's what that is it's no
one her knew that that's a good answer
did anyone suppose it doing this yes
they did
well done it everybody else kept saying
that's a really nice necklace that's
gorgeous and sudeikis of course walks
right up to me and goes is that a [ __ ]
ring really well you've just given me
some insight into your sweet personal
life yeah all I knew what it was too
[Music]
[Applause]
poor ollie yeah I know you what you do
this to me
I guess no one told you life was gonna
be this way
[Applause]
we've been here since five across her
her
you guys have been rehearsing so I guess
no one told you life is gonna be this
way actually here's the game now I'm not
gonna say it again
but if anyone else wants to feed it into
conversation don't let me down really
good so far
what's the line again oh no one ever
told you life is gonna be look at me I'm
trying to remember it taller that was
gonna be this thing
[Music]
I'm gonna wear dame judi dench out on
that
[Music]
you